bonjour m freyssinet bonjour comment
savoir on met ça va bien vous mais moi
ça va très bien bienvenue dans la partie
et ben merci c'est rare c'est une
demande que mangerait ah bah moi je
demande toujours aux gens comment ils
vont tous bien ces ouvriers du canada ça
me fait un petit peu du du québec et du
canada mais c'est aussi quelque chose
que que je faisais un peu avant j'aime
bien j'ai pas de bienséance non mais
même ça s'installe un contact humain
quoi et les gens ils sont surpris un
tout le temps ça me l'a fait hier hier
j'appelle un voile à 2 c les klein de
services et leur dit bonjour comment
allez vous il a buggé démissionner ça va
ça va et puis tout de suite c'est pas ça
mais un truc humain je trouve que des
fois ça fait du bien quoi et pourtant ce
semble être le bea va effectivement
c'est pas si fréquent bah c'est pour ça
je pense que ça coûterait 1 personne et
si on l'installé on gagnerait tous en
bonne humeur nous les français les
parisiens on n'est pas super généreux
pas super ouvert je me suis posé la
question en fait je me suis dit si les
gens et ne demande pas comment ça va
c'est parce qu'en vrai à paris il ya
cette idée que ça va jamais à cette idée
là évidemment ça va prêcher en train de
poser comme je suis en train de bosser
là tu crois vraiment que ça va être
vraiment je compte en état et en même
temps il ya ce truc de
on s'oublie beaucoup derrière la
fonction le travail on est souvent dans
cette idée de quand on travaille on
n'est pas un humain on est une fonction
et je trouve qu'il faut pas oublier
qu'on est des humains parce que souvent
ça rend le travail plus agréable alors
j'espère que c'est à dire pour vous
d'être ici d'habitude vous arriver plus
tôt dans les dernières minutes de
l'émission durant ce clic le samedi midi
là toute une émission rien que vous et
moi ouais ça vous va bien avec grand
plaisir à mes grands plaisirs et puis en
même temps rien que vous et moi et en
même temps je vais pas vous mentir je me
sens un petit peu seul dans son
appartement
qu'est-ce qui vous tente a priori
regardez il ya quand même pas mal de il
ya pas mal de possibilités par mal de
possibilités bon déjà j'ai été un peu
surpris parce que visiblement vous êtes
très bien renseignés alors je sais pas
même qui vous a enseigné là dessus mais
tous les albums qui sont là cd album que
je trouve extraordinaire
mon ami ni notre hockey ben je vois bien
je vois bien je vois que pas besoin de
colombo ces prochaines enquêtes on va
vous appeler vous
voilà très bien alors écoutez on est
ravi de vous avoir vous avez 27 ans oui
vous êtes très jeune très avant gardiste
humoriste spécialiste du stand vous avez
déjà écrit quatre spectacles intitulés
migraine là au delà en trois mois je
précise et puis alors vous êtes des
millions de vues sur youtube vous êtes
devenus célèbres intervenant dans les
dernières minutes de l'émission cliquer
de mouloud achour sur canal+ bien sûr on
a pu découvrir humour surréaliste qui
fait rire qui fait qu'il faut aussi
gambergé encore m il faut le dire la
jusqu'ici je suis dans le vrai gilles
étape importante oui bah après c'était
très c'était très flatteur c'était très
gentil je sais pas si mes oui tous les
tous les faits sont vrais
j'ai écrit beaucoup
passer dans l'émission de mouloud achour
clic m'a fait rencontrer un public large
et m'a amené de la notoriété et quand et
quand la presse s'empare de vous il
commence libé par exemple il commence à
parler du grand espoir du stand français
à l'humour surréaliste l'express qui va
avec son jeune surdoué du stand-up le
petit prince du stand pour le figaro
vous mettez la presse d'accord et tous
les courants de 13 allée dire d'accord
enfin ils sont gentils ils sont gentils
après bon des fois
[Musique]